madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce samedi 25 août
nous irons ce soir en grèce la balle
pays vit une terrible vague d' incendies
dus à la canicule
les flammes sont désormais aux portes
d'athènes le bilan est dramatique plus
de quarante cinq victimes
la mort de raymond barre l'ancien
premier ministre est décédé à l'âge de
83 ans la nuit dernière au val de grâce
à paris
nous reviendrons sur le parcours de cet
homme politique atypique qui a toujours
voulu se situer au dessus de la mêlée sa
disparition a suscité de nombreuses
réactions aujourd'hui ségolène royal est
de retour l'ex candidate à la
présidentielle a réuni aujourd'hui ses
plus fidèles partisans dans son fief des
deux sèvres à la firme être une femme 9
qui a accompli sa mutation cent jours
après sa défaite
elle appelle à la réconciliation au
travail collectif mais pour quel
rénovation nous lui poserons la question
ce soir elle est l'invitée de ce journal
le grand retour des vacances se poursuit
sur les routes de france beaucoup non
dans la vallée du rhône mais également
autour de la capitale et des français
qui espère profiter des week-ends à
venir pour apprécier enfin un soleil qui
leur a bien manqué cet été enfin
portrait à suivre ce soir celui de
l'homme qui pourrait devenir la star de
la future coupe du monde de rugby
sébastien chabal deuxième ligne du
quinze de france suscite toutes les
attentions depuis quelques semaines
celle du public des médias mais aussi et
surtout celle de ses futurs adversaires
avant de revenir sur la disparition de
l'ancien premier ministre raymond barre
commençons ce journal par les dernières
informations et les dernières images en
provenance de grèce là bas le pays vit
donc un véritable cauchemar depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant des dizaines
d' incendies sont en train de dévaster
le péloponnèse une région située dans le
sud du pays
le bilan n'a cessé d'évoluer depuis les
dernières heures passant à plus de 45
victimes
le point ce soir avec karine comazzi
les grecs ont coutume de l'appeler la
terre des dieux mais le plus au poney
offre aujourd'hui un spectacle
d'apocalypse attisés par des vents
violents et chaud le feu dévore les
collines et s'invite jusque dans les
villes à l'ouest de la péninsule dans la
province de zacharo les habitants
reculée force à partir ceux qui
voudraient rester car la lutte est
inégale dans ce village c'est le feu qui
a gagné au milieu des cadavres d'années
de chèvre une vieille habitante
arpentent les rues désertes
je n'ai pas de famille ils sont tous à
athènes mon mari est mort
j'ai passé toute la nuit tout seul ici
comment aurais je pu manger je n'ai
aucun moyen au village 35 personnes ont
été prises au piège par la 118
carbonisés dans leur voiture parmi elles
une femme tenant ses quatre enfants ces
femmes y étaient de retour au village
chez leurs parents pour les vacances
d'été
ceux ci ont pu s'enfuir d'autres sont
restés que voulez vous je vous dise
la nuit dernière deux ou trois d'entre
nous sommes restés ici on a vu des morts
sur la route certains méconnaissables
fans
qu'est ce que je peux dire de plus de 17
avions sept hélicoptères les moyens sont
insuffisants pour intervenir sur les 90
foyers de la péninsule au sud
arrêt au poly 4 vacances et auraient
trouvé la mort sans que les autorités
réunies par le premier ministre costas
caramanlis puisse encore déterminer leur
identité
le feu gagne le nord de la péninsule
coréenne et menace même les environs de
la capitale athènes une tragédie
nationale selon les grecs un grand
malheur que les pop essaye par tous les
moyens de conjurer
et le ciel d'athènes c'est donc à son
tour assombrit les incendies se sont en
effet déclarés également aujourd'hui aux
portes de la capitale
et ce soir les flammes située à quelques
kilomètres du centre ne sont toujours
pas maîtrisés
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux franck
gêne au zoo et marie cros l'arrivée à
athènes donne un avant-goût de la
situation en grèce vu du ciel une
multitude de petits foyers et à perte de
vue
un panache de fumée qui donne
l'impression d'un pays en feu et la
capitale n'est pas épargné rien
qu'aujourd'hui trois fours de grignoter
la banlieue d'athènes certains accès à
la ville ont même été coupée pendant
plusieurs heures le temps pour le feu
d'enjamber l'autoroute alors hélicoptère
et canadair ont dû matraque l incendie
pour éviter qu'ils ne détruisent les
premières habitations
le feu a traversé la rue il a touché
quelques maisons et presque brûlé une
école pour faire face les pompiers ne
sont pas assez nombreux alors ce sont
les habitants eux mêmes qui prennent en
main les lances à incendie pour tenter
de sauver leur maison et c'est en fait
toute une chaîne de solidarité qui se
met en place chez les riverains ont
creusé on ratisse le sol pour étouffer
les dernières braises avec ce vent fort
le jeu peut renaître très vite again
alors on va rester debout toute la nuit
pour surveiller
on distribue également de l'eau aux
réservistes de l'armée venus en renfort
pour évacuer les dix religieuse de ce
monastère
heureusement qu'ils sont là c'est grâce
aux habitants que le feu ne s'est pas
propagé mais avec une multitude
d'incendié à athènes depuis le début de
l'été les corps et les esprits
commencent à être usées
ce soir le vent est tombé mais demain
les températures pourraient à nouveau
flirter avec les 40 degrés alors à la
moindre étincelle
il faudra tout recommencer
alors quelle est la situation désormais
on retrouve sur place notre envoyé
spécial franck geinoz au bon soir franck
tout d'abord est ce que le bilan humain
risque de s'alourdir dans les prochaines
heures
absolument le tout dernier bilan que
nous avons en notre possession a fait
état de 50 morts en deux jours dans le
péloponnèse et c'est un bilan qui
devrait s'alourdir dans les heures à
venir parce que les secours ont les
pires difficultés à se rendre jusqu'en 2
jusque dans des villages reculés dans
des zones très escarpées
évidemment le vent très violent très
tourbillonnant vous voyez derrière moi
ne fallait sy ne facilite pas la tâche
et les hélicoptères de l'armée ont les
pires difficultés à évacuer les gens en
danger les agents du cas d'une vague d'
incendies sans précédent dans ce pays
absolument sans précédent vous l'avez
dit 170 feu recensés aujourd'hui sur le
territoire grec
dix mille hectares partis en fumée le
gouvernement a décidé de décréter un de
décréter l'état d'urgence
il a également décrété trois jours de
deuil la campagne législative qui pour
les élections législatives qui battait
son plein a été suspendue et les
autorités grecques sont obligés pour la
deuxième fois de l'été d'eau faire appel
à l'union européenne
merci franck l'actualité de ce samedi
est également marquée par la mort de
l'ancien premier ministre raymond barre
âgé de 83 ans l'ancien maire de lyon est
décédé cette nuit à l'hôpital du val de
grâce à paris
celui ci était hospitalisé depuis avril
dernier pour des problèmes cardiaques
le président de la république nicolas
sarkozy aime dans un communiqué souligné
l'esprit libre et indépendant de raymond
barre alors voyons quel a été le
parcours de cet homme politique atypique
du professeur d'économie à l'homme
d'état centristes et européen convaincu
alexandre car c'est comme cela qu'on
perd sa voix et c'est comme ça qu'on ne
résout pas les problèmes
le franc parler c'est sa marque de
fabrique
en 1976 raymond barre entre dans le
gouvernement chirac comme ministre du
commerce extérieur
c'est le chef de l'état qui fait les
présentations
alors qui est monsieur bart monsieur
bart est sans doute le meilleur
économiste français six mois plus tard
jacques chirac démissionne raymond barre
devient premier ministre
un poste qu'il occupe jusqu'en 1981 ils
gardent économie et les finances pendant
deux ans je tiens à vous dire
immédiatement que je serais un premier
ministre économe de ses propos économe
aussi dans sa politique
un mot devient vite à la mode
l'austérité raymond barre veut ralentir
l'inflation et pour cela décident de
bloquer les prix et les salaires
la france manifeste lui tient bon
son pays c'est la réunion raymond barre
né en 1924 dans une famille de la
bourgeoisie créole son père est en fait
de mauvaises affaires quitte
définitivement ligne à quatre ans
raymond barre devient le seul homme de
la maison
c'est un élève brillant à 21 ans il
s'inscrit à la faculté de droit de paris
en ressort agrégé et rédigé un manuel
d'économie une référence en 1967
le professeur bart entre à la commission
européenne sur ses conseils de gaulle
refuse de dévaluer le franc en 1968
rien ne sert de courir dans une campagne
aime-t-il rappeler il faut partir à
point
soutenu par les centristes le député du
rhône toujours réélu est souvent
caricaturée pour son flegme et ses bons
mots je suis dans la vraie france
je ne suis pas dans le microcosme en
1986 raymond barre s'oppose à la
cohabitation
deux ans plus tard il annonce sa
candidature décidé d'être candidat à la
présidence la république 16,5 pour cent
des voix il ne passe pas le premier tour
du bout des lèvres
raymond barre appelle à voter jacques
chirat à l'assemblée comme dans
l'univers politique qui fait figure de
sage tout souvent consulté à droite
comme à gauche
en 1995 raymond barre devient maire de
lyon avec lui se développent de grands
chantiers lyon s'offre un nouveau visage
celui d'une métropole européenne
après six ans à la tête de la ville
raymond barre ne se représente pas un an
plus tard il quitte l'assemblée
nationale depuis ses apparitions se font
rares mais pourtant à l'occasion de la
promotion de ses mémoires il défend
maurice papon et bruno gollnisch et
dénonce un lobby juif capable de monter
des opérations indigne v par une ombre
sur la fin de vie de cet homme
unanimement respectée sous la vème
république raymond barre reste un homme
atypique indépendant loin des appareils
des partis à sa façon un homme à part
depuis l'annoncé du décès de raymond
barre les réactions se sont multipliées
tout au long de la journée jacques
chirac salue un grand économiste et un
homme engagé pour la modernisation du
pays
autre réaction ce matin celle du premier
ministre françois fillon mais également
celle de l'ancien président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing ou
encore du centriste françois bayrou on
écoute leurs réactions
mais qu ahmed tazir et arnaud wicht il a
décidé d'écourter ses vacances dans le
midi
dès l'annoncé du décès valéry giscard
d'estaing a tenu le premier à saluer la
mémoire de son ancien premier ministre
était le meilleur premier ministre de
notre pays de placer longtemps en
réalité on se tient un travailleur
acharné une peut dépenser à colbert ce
qu'on apprend que quand colbert arrivait
le matin sur son bureau qui fait des
piles de dossiers qui se frottait les
mains de plaisir mais rarement passé un
peu sa nouvelle relation entre le
travail 7 7 pour lui une sorte de drogue
il se plonger dans le travail depuis son
fief de la sarthe le premier ministre
salue à l'esprit indépendant courageux
et francs raymond barre c'était au fond
une référence dans la vie politique
française et à ce titre
sa voix son regard sa silhouette à la
fois un peu bonhomme et en même temps
très rigoureuse va manquer aux français
un esprit carré dans un corps au service
de l'intérêt général l'expression
revient souvent surtout dans sa famille
politique d'être un homme d'état c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui m'était l'interêt
général de son pays au dessus des
intérêts particuliers au dessus des
intérêts de parti au dessus de ses
intérêts propres
mais ils avaient cette cette
dimension-là qui faisait naître la
confiance parce qu'on savait que celui
là au moins disait la vérité
la gauche se souvient aussi de l'homme
d'état indépendant et de l'économiste
qui fait autorité capable de
bienveillance aux pires moments de la
vie que quand je suis tombé valable il
ya un mois et demi maintenant on a assez
gravement
il avait deux sont les devants dès son
fils nicolas qui l'a fait mme adresser
un petit message
c'est magnifique ce merveilleux moi je
dialogue avec tout le monde parce que je
suis un homme libre
n'oubliez pas ça les obsèques de cet
homme libre devrait avoir lieu mercredi
au val-de-grâce l'hôpital militaire
parisien où il est décédé
et c'est à lyon que raymond barre
installé sa carrière politique député à
plusieurs reprises maire de la ville de
1995 à 2001 il restera comme l'homme des
grands chantiers de la deuxième ville de
france voyons aujourd'hui comment la
population et les figures de la ville
ont réagi à sa disparition de nice et
bastien thiry simonet la nouvelle s'est
répandue au fil de la journée et les
drapeaux en berne sont venus l'a
confirmé député du rhône
raymond barre avait aussi occupé le
fauteuil de maire pendant un mandat
un maire qui n'étaient pas originaires
de la ville mais qui avait su se faire
apprécier par une partie de la
population
en effet né mais compte tenu de son âge
savait qu'il avait une santé qui était
fragile je pense qu'il a quand même
donné à lyon une renommée internationale
parce que je pense que c'est quand il
était maire que lyon a été inscrit au
patrimoine de l'unesco
il était rigoureux dans son travail
humaniste il a fait beaucoup
c'est dommage qu'il n'est pas resté
longtemps quoi l'afrique cisa n'y
allions y est déjà
4h15 et je ne tiens pas à ce que nous
passions notre temps à savoir si nous
sommes bien photographier ou non raymond
barre qui rabroue les journalistes voilà
pour le style direct
il dirige est ici son dernier conseil
municipal à lyon ses partisans comme ses
adversaires politiques lui rendent
hommage s'étaient pas quelqu'un de
manichéen et était prêt à écouter les
idées de l'autre à partager ses avis
fort monsieur bah quand une idée était
bonne l'été boni alors ne regardez pas
qu'il avait formulées souvent critique
vis-à-vis des querelles lyonnaise
raymond barre s'était en revanche bien
adapté à l'un des aspects de la vie
entre saône et rhône
la gastronomie paul bocuse se souvient
de ses visites fréquentes et de son
appétit toussaint gourmands et aux
gourmets vins je pense que il aimait les
choses simples et chose si vous l'aimez
bien bon plat mais qui est consistant
c'est à dire qu'on puisse faire deux
fois
un registre de condoléances a été ouvert
devant la mairie lundi soir une veillée
aura lieu dans les salons de l'hôtel de
ville
cent jours après l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy à la présidence de la république
et donc son jours après sa défaite
ségolène royal a fait son retour sur la
scène politique retour sur cette terre
dans son fief à melle dans les deux
sèvres
l'ex candidate du parti socialiste est
apparue offensive mais elle souhaite
prendre son temps sur place reportage
défi d'un verre et aurélien chapalain
les militants qui lui sont fidèles ont
bien fait les choses
il y a du monde visiblement pour le
retour de ségolène royal
ses compagnons de route qui son fief de
melle quelques cartes socialiste
et voilà la fête de la rose qui prend un
petit air de campagne même les drapeaux
ont été ressortis j'ai quelque chose à
vous dire mais je ne suis en compétition
avec personne
traduction ni dominique strauss kahn
désormais devant elle dans les sondages
ni françois hollande ne l'inquiète moins
de sérénité pour commenter les livres
signés par des socialistes et qui
reviennent durement sur sa campagne
je crois que ça fait quand même beaucoup
de dégâts au delà de la vulgarité de
certains propos jean louis bianco à côté
de lui michèle delaunay la tombeuse
d'alain juppé des têtes qu'on a
découverte ou redécouverte ségolène
royal affiche ses troupes et sa nouvelle
méthode elle ne donnera pas dans
l'opposition frontale à nicolas sarkozy
pourquoi par exemple reconnaître qu'il y
a dans ce nouveau pouvoir
une volonté de réforme seulement
annoncer la réforme ce n'est pas
l'accomplir 1h30 de discours
le public était content id abbas et les
français la gueule c'est pas parce
qu'ils disent quelle partie la halle est
de retour dans une semaine devant
l'ensemble des socialistes réunis à la
rochelle ségolène royal sait qu'elle
n'aura pas forcément le même succès
c'est pourquoi cette année elle tenait à
fixer sa ligne avant les autres et on
retrouve maintenant à amel ségolène
royal qui est notre invité bonsoir
madame royal merci d'être avec nous ce
soir
première question toute simple vous
aviez reconnu et c'est légitime être
fatigué à la fin de cette campagne
électorale
alors tout d'abord comment allez vous
après cette trêve estivale je vous
remercie de vous préoccuper de demont
les temps mais je vais très bien bien
évidemment je n'étais pas fatigué au
sens où c'est vrai cette campagne aussi
m'avait donné énormément d'énergie mais
c'est vrai je crois que le fait de
de faire un arrêt de réfléchir de
profiter de ses enfants de sa famille de
ses amis je crois que c'est des moments
très importants comme pour tous les
français sincèrement qu est ce que l'on
ressent après des mois de campagne
lorsque tout cela s'arrête
est ce qu'il ya un grand vide pas du
tout je suis aujourd'hui une femme très
sereine et en même temps je ne suis
animé d'aucun esprit de revanche
c'est à dire que nouvelle page de
l'histoire maintenant on va s'écrire
pour la gauche pour les socialistes
nous avons beaucoup de travail à faire
d'abord réfléchir bien évidemment sur
les raisons de la défaite mais ne pas le
faire avec nostalgie
au contraire le faire en étant en
position solide par rapport à ce que les
français attendent
moi je crois qu'il faut réinventer une
nouvelle façon d'agir dans l'opposition
c'est à dire faire comme si nous étions
aussi aux responsabilités et pousser en
avant le gouvernement actuel à agir et à
accomplir les réformes pour que la
france ne régresse pas moi je crois
qu'il faut reconnaître à ce gouvernement
un certain nombre de mérite pour que les
critiques ou les propositions qui sont
faites soit davantage crédible je veux
reconnaître au gouvernement de nicolas
sarkozy et même à lui-même une capacité
de mouvement de réactivité mais ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il ne faut pas que
ce mouvement se transforme en
impuissance
lorsque par exemple il le promet pour
lutter contre la délinquance sexuelle et
contre les pédophiles après ce drame
affreux de mettre en place un hôpital
réservé pour les délinquants sexuels je
veux lui dire que cette promesse a déjà
été fait il ya trois ans et
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une forme de risque
d' immobilisme mémorial je crois qu'il
faut et je crois qu'il faut en finir
avec l'accumulation par exemple des lois
ou des commissions qui sont mises en
place
mais vraiment passer à l'action pour
répondre aux problèmes qui se posent aux
français en particulier pour trouver des
solutions au ralentissement de la
croissance maintenant moyal l'actualité
c'est également celle du parti
socialiste si je vous demandais de
donner un diagnostic du parti socialiste
vous diriez qu'il est fiévreux
convalescents ou très malade
je dirais qu'il est très fort dans sa
base dans sa masse de militants et
c'était ici plus de 3000 tout à l'heure
très volontariste dans sa volonté
d'avancer de préparer l'avenir mais en
même temps qu'ils doutent qu'il doute de
lui-même qu'il doit aussi remettre en
cause un certain nombre de dogmes et en
particulier je crois que nous avons la
capacité à réconcilier la notion
d'efficacité économique et de justice
sociale que nous devons aussi
réconcilier la protection de l'année
voilà des propos recueillis en fin
d'après-midi dans le reste de
l'actualité un produit répulsif pour
faire fuir les sdf voilà l'étrange idée
émise par le maire d'argenteuil en
banlieue parisienne pour éloigner les
sans abri du centre ville le maire s'est
procuré ce produit nauséabond pour que
les lieux occupés par les sdf en soient
aspergés pour le moment les agents de la
voirie s'y sont refusés explication est
la coudraie et vincent kelner le plus
viril thater j'ai envie surtout
cherche pas midi à quatorze heures
partout partout partout
dominique est sdf depuis un an il vit
aux abords d'un centre commercial en
plein coeur d'argenteuil avec sa
compagne
le produit a été favorisée par les
agents d'entretien de la galerie
marchande
il pourrait s'agir de malodore un
répulsif non toxique selon son fabricant
mais qui dégage une odeur nauséabonde
l'objectif chasser les sdf du centre
ville notre bonne mal on est comme ça en
sdf on a besoin on a construit un déjà
un abri c'est la municipalité qui a
donné le produit au centre commercial
dans un premier temps elle avait demandé
à ses propres agents qui ont refusé
on utilise des produits pour se
débarrasser des parasites et voilà c'est
pas des parasites céder les gens c'est
des gens quoi joue dit pour moi c'est
plus que chaud qu'on fait ces combats
d'un prompt à la mairie on affirme que
le produit n'a pas été utilisés
jusqu'ici mais on n'exclut pas cette
possibilité à l'avenir
le fait même de leur dire qu'on va
peut-être être obligés d'utiliser ce
produit
c'est peut-être un moyen de les
convaincre d'accepter les solutions
sociales et on ne fait là que suivre ce
qui se passe dans d'autres communes dans
les autres communes le mano d'or est
utilisé dans des endroits dangereux sous
des ponts ou près des routes
jamais encore dans le but de chasser des
personnes du centre ville et ce sur la
ministre du logement christine boutin
jugé inacceptable l'utilisation de
produits répulsifs et promet des
initiatives respectant la dignité des
sdf comme prévu vous avez été nombreux à
prendre la route du retour des vacances
aujourd'hui des ralentissements et
quelques bouchons surtout concentrées
dans le sens des retours dans la vallée
du rhône où on ile de france et a donc
fallu parfois pendant son mal en
patience et parfois s'accorder une
petite pause comme ici sur cette terre
d'autoroute près de tours caroline
thébaux antoine morel
et un deux trois à chacun sa méthode
pour se détendre après avoir avalé les
kilomètres et surtout à chacun son
dernier sandwichs des vacances jambon
fromage couler sandwich et blanc coule
et mayonnaise
c'est la fin des vacances et même s'il
n'y a plus de châteaux de sable tout est
bon pour se sentir encore en congés et
s'assurer un retour en toute
tranquillité après manger salé découlent
comme ça après dans la voiture et
pourront bien se calmer et bien sans
dormir moins pour sa tranquillité
mais l'étude une aire de ton imac est
rarement de tout reprendre
cole évolutions extrêmes il ya du monde
pour faire pousser les bébés à la presse
qu'il fait du bien
de retour pas de files d'attentes en
revanche pour eux et qui le met très
patient on en profite dernière balade
dernier flirt et pour certains derniers
temps à la dorlot donc comme vous pouvez
voir la vallée ça lui fait du bien donc
les dieux qu'elle aime allah d'or à la
dore n'y a aucun problème
pas le temps de s'éterniser c'est
l'heure de reprendre la route
même si le soleil 3 enfin le bouc son
courage et si jamais le retour est trop
dure la prochaine ère et dans dix
minutes
elle était un été maussade un ciel
triste un soleil trop rare sur une
grande partie nord et ouest du pays
c'est pourquoi certains d'entre vous
entendent profiter dans les semaines à
venir des week-ends on l'espère
ensoleillé ce fut le cas aujourd'hui à
cabourg l'occasion pour certains de
retarder le retour du quotidien jean
françois feer et et france ô pitrel dans
la précipitation
ils en ont même oublié les pelles et les
sauts ce matin en ouvrant leurs volets
de rueil malmaison en région parisienne
les romillons ont une vision d'horreur
de la pluie et de la grisaille encore
une seule idée leur est venue en tête
sauve qui peut on a une semaine
absolument catastrophique on s'est dit
ce matin en écoutant les prévisions
météo il a l'air de faire bois la mer ou
par chat et hop
envoituresimone direction cabourg à deux
heures de route de paris bonne pioche
drapeau vert et grand soleil pour tout
le monde dira que c'est un petit bonus
pour les vacancières commence à me voir
à voir brouillard à couper au couteau
non pas la peine de se plaindre jeune
homme ni même de courir après le soleil
il a tenu bon toute la journée 22 degrés
seulement un peu frisquet pour la saison
mais c'est la première vraie belle
journée depuis des semaines on vient de
loin pour l'apprécier c'est le
débarquement sur la plage de normandie
moi je viens de nice par les liens du
val d'oise de l'isle-adam exactement ce
qu'il y ait des yvelines et on trouve
même mais oui des chinois étonnant ils
viennent pêcher la palourde à cabourg
si vous l'écoutez c'est vachement
intéressante oui vous vous mangez pas
ici c'est new lot
c'est indécent pour la pêche à la
palourde ou tout simplement pour la
baignade
quatre cent mille touristes viennent ici
chaque été quatre cent mille touristes
pour 3542 qu'à bourges est très
accueillant c'est une belle plage qui
mérite d'être connue et qu'elle soit
fréquenté par des parisiens et
différentes nationalités jean prouvost
et profitez bien de la vue car dès la
semaine prochaine le temps se gâte
aujourd'hui ce n'était donc peut-être
pas vraiment le jour oubliée son maillot
de bain certains l'attendaient d'autres
la critique c'était ce matin l'ouverture
de la chasse au gibier d'eau 250 mille
chasseurs étaient au rendez vous une
ouverture un peu morose cette année en
raison des restrictions dues à la grippe
aviaire reportage à condé sur l'escaut
dans le nord 2 à palau et chloé le
compte bancaire du matin il fait encore
venu sur ce marais du valenciennois
pourtant philippe et grégory s'affairent
déjà dans une heure la chasse est
ouverte
il faut placer les derniers à plan grâce
à leurs cris ses canards élevés par les
chasseurs serveuse d'absents pour le
chip lead ou non mais frau c'était laid
et plusieurs de l'autre côté reprendre
le gibier qui va revenir naulleau ce
matin normalement
quelques minutes plus tard le jour se
lève tout est prêt dans la hutte les
filets appelons résonnent au loin en
toute illégalité car le gouvernement l'a
décidé le canard a pas son teint faire
du cirque les gens dans les marais il
pourrait favoriser la propagation du
virus h5n1 une décision ressenti ici
comme une injuste on met en colère mais
au fait on refait pas voir quoi et puis
on choses comme ça quoi tant pis pour
eux quoi une nouvelle balise rohu nous
verbalise rond mais comme un état comme
ici peuvent pas nous verbaliser car six
en verbalisant toutes les ut doit
arriver qu ils peuvent pas verbalisés 38
sur un marais comme ça ils affirment
tous avoir mis les moyens pour garantir
la bonne santé et le suivi de ces
canards d'élevage pour toute la france
entre les bas d'entre eux les les
analyses et aux on approche du 1
millions 5,2 euros c'est pas rien
soudain quelques tirs retentissent pour
la plupart infructueux pas de quoi
consoler aujourd'hui ces chasseurs de
gibier d'eau
ils se disent même découragés par cette
nouvelle interdiction dans le nord près
de 10% d'entre eux auraient décidé
l'année dernière de raccrocher le fusil
l'actualité sportive de ce samedi avec
tout d'abord un premier résultat de
football quand recevais en fin d'après
midi l'olympique de marseille et c'est
l'om qui s'est imposé 2 buts à 1 but de
rodriguez et de mamadou niang à 6 ce
soir monaco le mans strasbourg lens ou
encore bordeaux lorient demain le paris
saint-germain rencontre lille et
saint-etienne se déplace pour le derby à
lyon résultats reportages analyses
demain dès midi dans france de foot je
vous le dise en titre il pourrait
devenir l'une des stars de la prochaine
coupe du monde de rugby sébastien chabal
a été propulsé icône médiatique
en quelques semaines il faut dire que
l'homme d'un mètre 92 de 115 kg un
physique que ses adversaires n'oublie
pas en général une image d'un guerrier
ombrageux qui interpelle alors qui est
cet homme souvent caricaturé peut-on
parler aujourd'hui de chabalmania
tentons d'en savoir plus ce soir avec un
montant si tu es zidène berkous
voici mesdames messieurs la nouvelle
coqueluche de l'équipe de france
un mètre 92 115 kilos de muscles
sébastien chabal arrivant à
l'entraînement et si ce n'est par ses
coéquipiers et deux mots pour le définir
animal et bestial tueur à gages je
dirais roi la preuve par l'image
cet hiver la france est en tournée
chabal eux au plaquage un néo zélandais
en moins une semaine plus tard le
français repart au combat
résultat une mâchoire de fracture et ses
faits d'armes sont visionnées des
dizaines de milliers de fois sur
internet
à son retour en france il a l'honneur
des plateaux télé
quoi
la chabalmania gagne du terrain non pas
aux quelque part son niveau b mais sinon
pas du tout ce qui est important
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui se lamentant
reçu terrain et ses derniers temps sur
le terrain difficile de faire sans lui
un essai face à l'angleterre et tout le
monde s'emballe pour chabal surtout si
chouchou sébastien chabal qui nous a
fait une chevauchée héroïque sébacées
chauvet ministre rachida dati de passage
à marcquois s'ils tombent elles aussi
sous le charme
un phénomène ce chat balle fille qui
aime les garçons un peu viril voilà donc
j'ai l'impression que sébastien chabal
il évoque sa et les chevelus des poilus
il a une barbe
il ya un côté un peu christie chabal
cultive son corps autant que les
paradoxes pour cette coupe du monde le
rugbyman préféré des français risque
fort de jouer les remplaçants de luxe un
rôle de sauveur dans lequel ils
excellent sport toujours avec les
championnats du monde d'athlétisme qui
ont commencé à osaka au japon le
français mehdi baala a pris ses marques
en se qualifiant sur 1500 m mais épreuve
marquée par une chaleur accablante
reportage sur place manuel tisser et
yann one la médaillée d'or
le soleil est de plomb le kenyan qui met
remporté le premier titre des mondiaux
2h16 de marathon pour le vainqueur mais
une matinée en enfer pour tous les
concurrents 30 degrés à l'ombre
à 7 heures du matin 62 % d'humidité 42
km 195 souffrante
une trentaine de ces marathoniens n'a
même pas vu la ligne d'arrivée et pour
le dossard numéro 10 ce fut d'extrême
justesse
dans ces conditions extrêmes l'entrée en
piste de mehdi baala présentait quelques
risques
mais le double champion d'europe du 400
mètres l'un des favoris pour la médaille
s'est facilement qualifié pour les demi
finales meilleur temps des séries
moi je vais quand même l'impression
d'être un petit peu écrasée voiture leur
a surtout conduit son petit show très
froid on foncera beyoncé zorbit on
transpire la rade par la chaleur
multiplie aussi les risques d'accidents
et la rivière du 3000 m steeples nord
pour une fraîcheur
la performance de la jeune française
sophie duarte est d'autant plus relevée
elle a mené presque toute la course et
se qualifier à 26 ans pour sa première
finale mondiale
bonne soirée aussi panda mannequin et à
vainqueur de sa série du 400 m haies est
ravi de retrouver enfin l'été a pour moi
c'est un grand plaisir moi qui me
ockrent en région parisienne même
jusqu'à maintenant il parle qui peut
encore et la température n'a pas fini de
grimper
le jamaïcain powell et l'américain guèye
ont commencé leur duel à distance sur
100 m demain ils auront le record du
monde en ligne de miel trois journées
avec les stars du rock comme bjork ans
quand les rita mitsouko ou tel programme
alléchant proposé par la cinquième
édition du festival rock en seine qui se
déroule à saint cloud à côté de paris
reste à savoir ce que signifie être
rock'n'roll aujourd'hui elle brigue chi
et tristan le bras sont allés enquêter
sur place
rock en seine pendant que certains
passent leur fin d'été à bulles et
d'autres révisent leur leçon de rock n
roll les trois sujets difficiles
quelques minutes à peine pour le traité
il faut faire vite
direction la loge du groupe parisien
rock and roll avec un nom pareil il doit
bien connaître la réponse des gens
vers le conte sur scène et boire des
biens après mais c'est aussi boire des
bières grand mince on est tombés sur des
cancres vaut mieux discuter avec emilie
simon auteur de la bande originale du
film la marche de l'empereur
non
pour moi le rock c'est une question
d'énergie pure après ça passe par jacky
tard par
2 je sais pas la base ou des synthés ou
de pain porte finalement
même son de cloche chez le groupe spir
eyes dans le rock c'est l'énergie qui
prime
vous pouvez avoir des trucs très malin
dans le rock mais si la chanson ne vous
donne pas envie de sourire danser ça n'a
aucun sens
mais le petit manège de ces suédois ne
convainc pas les nostalgiques du bon
vieux rock'n'roll et vous ça les gens
ont dit que leurs occupants 75 ou est ce
que je veux dire
mais non c'est l'évolution
mort ou pas ils étaient près de 20000
hier pour assister au concert d'arcade
fire
du rock du vrai avec un ukulélé
le festival se termine demain soir plus
qu'un jour pour réviser son petit regain
droit d'illustrer
humour
tous voilà pour l'actualité de ce samedi
comme vous avez pu constater un incident
technique s'est produit à propos de
l'unité avec madame royal nous vous
prions de nous en excuser merci à vous
d'avoir suivi ce journal ne manquez pas
la météo
nathalie rihouet à 20h50 fort boyard je
vous retrouve demain dès 13h passé une
très belle soirée sur france 2
tous
m